and struggle so hard just to survive.
Even after learning a new language and getting a job,
their whole world can be turned upside down in an instant.
That's why, after 10 years of hiding my identity,
I decided to risk going to South Korea.
And I started a new life yet again.
Settling down in South Korea
was a lot more challenging than I had expected.
English was so important in South Korea,
so I had to start learning my third language.
Also, I realized there was a wide gap between North and South.
We are all Korean, but inside,
we have become very different, due to 67 years of division.
I even went through an identity crisis.
Am I South Korean or North Korean?
Where am I from? Who am I?
Suddenly, there was no country I could proudly call my own.
Even though adjusting to life in South Korea was not easy,
I made a plan -- I started studying for the university entrance exam.
Just as I was starting to get used to my new life,
I received a shocking phone call.
The North Korean authorities intercepted some money
that I sent to my family,
and, as a punishment, my family was going to be forcibly removed
to a desolate location in the countryside.
They had to get out quickly.
So I started planning how to help them escape.
North Koreans have to travel incredible distances
on the path to freedom.
It's almost impossible to cross the border
between North Korea and South Korea.
So, ironically, I took a flight back to China
and headed toward the North Korean border.
Since my family couldn't speak Chinese,
I had to guide them somehow through more than 2,000 miles
in China, and then into Southeast Asia.
The journey by bus took one week,
and we were almost caught several times.
One time, our bus was stopped and boarded by a Chinese police officer.
He took everyone's I.D. cards,
and he started asking them questions.
Since my family couldn't understand Chinese,
I thought my family was going to be arrested.
As the Chinese officer approached my family,
I impulsively stood up, and I told him
that these are deaf and dumb people that I was chaperoning.
He looked at me suspiciously,
but luckily, he believed me.
We made it all the way to the border of Laos.
But I had to spend almost all my money
to bribe the border guards in Laos.
But even after we got past the border,
my family was arrested and jailed for illegal border crossing.
After I paid the fine and bribe,
my family was released in one month.
But soon after, my family was arrested and jailed again,
in the capital of Laos.
This was one of the lowest points in my life.
I did everything to get my family to freedom,
and we came so close,
but my family was thrown in jail,
just a short distance from the South Korean embassy.
I went back and forth between the immigration office
and the police station,
desperately trying to get my family out.
but I didn't have enough money to pay a bribe or fine anymore.
I lost all hope.
At that moment, I heard one man's voice ask me,
"What's wrong?"
I was so surprised that a total stranger cared enough to ask.
In my broken English, and with a dictionary,
I explained the situation, and without hesitating,
the man went to the ATM,
and he paid the rest of the money for my family,
and two other North Koreans to get out of jail.
I thanked him with all my heart, and I asked him,
"Why are you helping me?"
"I'm not helping you," he said.
"I'm helping the North Korean people."
I realized that this was a symbolic moment in my life.
The kind stranger symbolized new hope for me and the North Korean people,
when we needed it most.
And he showed me that the kindness of strangers
and the support of the international community
are truly the rays of hope we North Korean people need.
Eventually, after our long journey,
my family and I were reunited in South Korea.
But getting to freedom is only half the battle.
Many North Koreans are separated from their families,
and when they arrive in a new country,
they start with little or no money.
So we can benefit from the international community
for education, English language training, job training, and more.
We can also act as a bridge
between the people inside North Korea and the outside world.
Because many of us stay in contact with family members still inside,
and we send information and money
that is helping to change North Korea from inside.
I've been so lucky, received so much help and inspiration in my life,
so I want to help give aspiring North Koreans
a chance to prosper with international support.
I'm confident that you will see more and more North Koreans
succeeding all over the world,
including the TED stage.
Thank you.
(Applause)